here's Edie sit as an ox
with other known as an ox are you market
yeah I wouldn't want to look like at all
you don't look like enough if you look
amazing in this video thank you I've
slipped a bit from them have you yeah
well I kind of need but I kind of finish
the video and I was like right now it's
me they actually every day on that video
every day when we finished we went to
Buffalo Wild Wings and had six doing
speech was so drain during that and so
me and Jenny's ago because we were just
a whole day running and running and
punchy like it's obviously a
three-minute video but it was like a
three or four day shoot of constant
exercise so every day we just went and
just got carousing boneless buffalo
wings at the end of the day and you
showed your tattoos
I understand you have 60 oh it's more
than I don't know what you're talking
about it a lot more than things how many
probably wouldn't take the others arm
Wow do you have a favorite one
I got a Canadian one what supply nicely
what inspire that one uh the come as
Canada for the first time I can continue
to put more tattoos on because I
understand it fifty forty hours in a
span of 12 months to get attended it had
a lot longer than four years before this
was 18 hours but just the line was 18
ounce what's your next one um I don't
know yeah I don't know yeah there's a
nice cool Damien Hirst is drawing me a
little skull because we've worked
together on the album cover so I think
um I get that skull done alright I don't
know skull doesn't release I definitely
I go like cats and stuff on the other
nervous go woodsy well cats a good
subject as well because you have cats
right now all how many cats do you have
- three
yeah what yes three but but yeah - two
kitten kitten run are all so cute so you
know what I love about you is fulcrum
you know for her not to technically fool
you are you took 12 months off on your
own and took a break and that's
inspirational bright soft a lot of
people need to learn from that the
faculty need to take a step back and
from it you found love you found tryin
she found it before and that was why I
mean Rancheria being together from like
July 2015
so the 12 months was really just a spend
time together a millionaire she
she was getting very home so she lived
in New York and we grew up together and
she was getting very homesick and wanted
to move back to England to work and I
was finishing my talk and I was like
well why don't we take this opportunity
to do our gap years because we never we
never travelled I went straight into
Turin and she got scholarships an
American University so are you like the
happiest guy right now yeah yeah I just
found out that she's got an earlier
flight and she's coming to her for knows
month perfect that's amazing
she told you she has a hockey games
every Saturday I'm how the game is kind
of oh you mean she's played hockey field
hockey hockey field hockey yes so it
could be Canadian yeah she got you and
sheep then yeah well not not like out of
she wasn't like you're fat she actually
prefers me bigger and but yeah she just
would get up every morning go for a run
and I'd be like in bed as like a potato
like mother and I just started feeling
bad I was like okay if we can get off I
can get up so I just are running with it
and your ring there is a picture of you
wearing your wing on your wedding finger
I don't know if you saw it was actually
on this finger Davis gave the way around
and it blew your fans mine I think you
wouldn't do that yeah disincentives on
that it was on man wasn't it my wife are
talking about we're going crazy all you
know about the wedding finger no no I
know we'd go successful wedding ring
come on but it begs it's a question of
miss finger but look if you do right now
imagine what's gonna happen and people
see that and have a bad luck at all but
it makes a question if you were to get
engaged how would you set the tone which
you have a guitar o Yanna be children
would you well how would you do it how
did I yeah no I definitely wouldn't do
that
that sounds really cheesy speech sounds
really cheesy vehicle my on the beach
with the TV beautiful with a nice beach
but it was a nice beach and you doesn't
have any
my feature when they are just there
being like you know I don't know I don't
like that that's that's I know there's a
lot of stuff in the press but that is a
long way yet I just said that it feels
good chance but every like there's loads
of stuff at the press that I was meant
to do it yesterday yeah I don't know
like where that came from